your parents so they send in this
application to be in the in the Miss
India pageant were you kind of mortified
or were you like oh okay I'll go be in a
beauty pageant for context I think in
India like the pageants were really
revered and I know that in South America
it's the same a lot big parts of Europe
it's the same where you know there's a
lot of
um importance given to how eloquently
you speak how you behave I got a call I
happened to be home eating like meals
between my two classes or something
phone rang I picked it up and they were
like oh Miss India pageant we're calling
for Priyanka
um you have to be in Delhi in three days
bring a bathing suit don't wear makeup
and bring heels
um see there and I was like Priyanka who
Chopra okay okay great okay she gave me
the address I wrote it and I hung up and
I was like Mom look how famous I am they
know me
you had no idea they entered you because
I've come back from America right
wow you have a high opinion of yourself
such a dick
I know here in America you see all these
um documentaries on beauty pageants it's
a whole industry these beauty pageants
did you just charge up there and go and
walk around in a bathing suit and then
win
no we had about 30 days
to prep now I'm a competitive girl and
I'm very prep oriented so whenever I go
into a situation like in ninth grade I
didn't know how the cafeteria in America
Works in like a school like we bring
um lunch from home in India so I was
like all right I'm gonna observe this I
used to observe other students do it I
watched for about a week till I got
confident about you give the money you'd
get the tray like people put the food
whatever so that's just been my Approach
in general so 30 days leading up to the
pageant everybody else was a model they
gave us the opportunity to meet experts
in the field so hair and makeup would
come and meet us you know elocution
speaking walking talking all of that
happened over 30 days people were taking
up pictures you're meeting press
um and I just observed and learned and
learned and absorbed as much as I could
and I was just like the one thing I can
do is be smart up there and I know that
in India they look for that you want you
know the person representing the country
to be you know well spoken well you know
presentable traditional a good
Ambassador for your country you're up
against all these women in the Miss
India you win the Miss India they stick
you in this world against what 90
something women 96 women from around 96
women from around the world and you win
that one too yeah I was 18. Jerry
Springer R.I.P was our
um host that year wow it was in London
it was called a millennium Year from the
Millennium Miss World I guess there's
not going to be another one in our
lifetimes at the time that it seemed so
important to you was it like I gotta win
this thing oh yeah it was life and death
there's nothing else that mattered that
was like an athlete for me I was like
now that I'm here
I'm I can't lose it I'm too close like I
didn't aim for this but now that I'm
here I I see it I see the finish line
and I got it it's just I'm competitive
foreign